hello my name is yemi aladi
i am a musician and actor and also a
proud nigerian
and today i am part of a community
challenging one another to find ways to
reduce the amount of carbon emissions
globally today i am part of the
countdown and i'm super proud of that
unfortunately in nigeria we have been
experiencing climate change
and that is tripping away a lot of
beautiful things that the country is
known for well the music and culture
hasn't changed
it's what we do best it stayed the same
and i want to share
that with you right now so get ready
true love
let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
i'm forgetting
[Music]
true
[Music]
[Music]
happy new
[Music]
these
year
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
music
[Music]
um
[Music]
nowhere like africa
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
london usa nowhere
[Music]
[Music]
hey give it to me
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
new york chicago
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
it's an african one
[Music]
new york
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you